Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a South Korean
fantasy film called “Vanishing Time: A Boy
Who Returned.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the start of the movie, a child psychiatrist
interviews a girl named Soo-rin.
Soo-rin gets visibly nervous when the doctor
sets up a camera to record the interview.
She asks her to recite her story from the
beginning.
Soo-rin starts by saying that her mother married
Do-kyun some years ago.
Soon after the marriage, her mother passed
away and since then, Soo-rin has been living
with Do-kyun.
He is appointed to a construction site on
a ruler island named Hwano, so the two have
to move to the island.
After her mother’s death, Soo-rin has never
truly been happy.
She doesn’t talk much and isn’t fond of
her stepfather.
She is enrolled in a new school on the island
where she has the opportunity to make many
friends, but even then she prefers staying
alone.
Her stepfather has to work overnight as the
chief of a tunnel construction site.
Because of the explosions that take place
during the construction, the inhabitants of
the island are forbidden from entering the
construction area.
One night, Soo-rin goes through her phone
and reads comments on her blog about a wormhole.
When her mother died, Soo-rin wanted to run
away from the world, and while researching
ways to do that, she started to gain interest
in wormholes, supernatural beings, and so
on.
She talks to people on the internet about
such topics even on the school’s computer.
She accidentally leaves her computer open
which allows her classmates to read her comments
and make fun of her.
While returning home, Soo-rin meets a boy
named Sung-min who lives in an orphanage.
Sung-min introduces himself and tries to befriend
Soo-rin but she ignores him.
The next day during lunch, Soo-rin comes across
Sung-min and his friends talking about her
blog on the wormhole.
Sung-min claims to have entered another dimension
after reading it.
That day, Sung-min follows her behind as she
is walking home.
On being called out, he says that he believes
everything that she has written in the blog.
Out of their shared interest in supernatural
processes, the two become friends.
Soo-rin has developed her own alphabets to
communicate with Sung-min in secret.
They begin to use it daily to leave each other
notes in Soo-rin’s diary.
Every day after school, they go around town
looking for ghosts.
In one of such expeditions, Sung-min brings
Soo-rin to an abandoned wooden house in the
forest.
They explore the house and talk for a long
time while carving on wax blocks.
Soo-rin has started to fall in love with Sung-min.
She kisses him out of the blue making him
fluster.
One day, Soo-rin finds Sung-min and three
of his friends planning to go to the construction
site to watch the explosions.
She joins them and the kids make their way
through the woods so the grownups wouldn’t
see them.
When they cross the fence to the site, one
of the kids chickens out and runs back home.
The other four hide behind a cliff waiting,
but are disappointed when no explosions take
place.
While walking through the jungle, they come
across a tiny cave.
They decide to explore it and go inside one
after another.
Eventually, they come across a bright glowing
substance submerged in water at the end of
the cave.
Soo-rin assumes that it is a meteoroid.
Sung-min takes it upon himself to dive into
the water and bring the substance out.
On being brought out of the tunnel, the thing
stops glowing.
The kids notice that it looks like an egg.
One of the guys named Tae-shik claims that
the egg might belong to a time goblin.
His grandfather had once told him that on
full moon nights, a cave appears in the mountains
where the time goblin lives.
Whoever goes into the cave will come out as
an older person.
The other kids do not believe him since they
didn’t age.
Soo-rin discovers that her hairpin which was
a gift from her mother is missing.
She goes back into the cave to look for it
as the guys guard the egg.
She finds her pin but also notices that the
glowing egg is back in the water.
Confused, she comes out to see that the egg
has broken and her friends are missing.
She looks for them all around the jungle till
it gets dark.
She is eventually lost in the woods and has
to stay the night.
The following day a police force looks for
the kids in the woods.
Detective Ahn is made the head of the investigation.
Soon, the police find Soo-rin unconscious
in the woods.
Fortunately, she is alive and well.
In the hospital, the detective asks her what
happened to the other guys and she tells him
everything about the cave and the glowing
egg.
The detective and the adults do not believe
her story.
She even takes them to the jungle to show
them the cave but cannot find it.
It is almost as if it disappeared after the
full moon night.
Then, the detective is informed that the corpse
of one of the missing boys, Jae-wook, has
been found underground on a beach 20 KM away
from the town.
It is revealed that the cause of his death
was an asthma attack.
Since someone had to bury him underground,
the case turns from missing person to kidnapping.
Weeks pass after the incident but the other
two boys are not found.
Without Sung-min, Soo-rin turns into her older
introverted self.
She, too, is as confused as everyone but no
one believes her when she says the truth.
One day, she hears a noise from outside her
house.
On checking, she sees a man running to the
woods.
She follows him behind and enters deep into
the forest.
Some minutes into running, she falls to the
ground and the man also stops.
He approaches her and looks at her in fascination
as Soo-rin freezes in shock.
The man speaks for the first time and claims
that he is Sung-min.
On hearing his name, Soo-rin comes out of
her shocked state and runs away crying.
She ends up in front of Do-Kyun’s car and
hastily tells him about the man.
The police are informed about the incident
and they start searching the woods to look
for the man, assuming that he is the kidnapper.
Detective Ahn asks Soo-rin about the man and
she reveals that he was pretending to be Sung-min.
The policemen do not find the kidnapper but
they get their hands on Soo-rin’s diary
that she and Sung-min used to leave notes
for each other.
On seeing the pages, she is surprised because
they are filled with Sung-min’s notes.
Using their code language, he has written
about everything that happened after she went
into the cave to get her hairpin.
The guys get curious about what is inside
the egg, so Sung-min breaks it on the ground
without waiting for Soo-rin.
To their disappointment, it turns out to be
empty.
When Soo-rin doesn’t return for a while,
Sung-min goes inside the cave and sees that
she has frozen in her place.
He tries to talk to her and move her but she
doesn’t respond.
Moments later, he notices a drop of water
levitating mid-air.
He comes out of the cave and looks upwards
to see the birds have also frozen in the air.
The boys go to the town and see that everyone,
including their families have paused.
This makes them realize that time has frozen
for everyone except the three of them, meaning
that they can do anything they want.
For the first few days, they are on top of
the world.
They eat and drink whatever they like, sleep
whenever they want to, and play around the
entire day.
After a month or so, they get bored so they
decide to leave the island and go to another
city to see if they are actually the only
people on the earth who can move.
However, their plan is spoiled when they realize
that the water in the ocean has also stopped
flowing, which means that the boat will sink.
Back in the present, Soo-rin registers that
the man who approached her in the woods was
in fact Sung-min.
She stops reading as now getting the police
away from him is her first priority.
If they find him, they will surely arrest
him for being the kidnapper so she claims
to have lied about seeing anyone in the jungle.
The police believe her and she continues reading
the journal.
Many months later, the guys start to live
inside a tent in the mall.
Jae-wook’s health gets worse by the day
because he has asthma and his inhaler stops
working.
One night, he suffocates and slowly passes
away in front of his friends.
Sung-min and Tae-shik are devastated.
With a heavy heart, they bury their friend’s
corpse under the ground on a nearby beach.
After dying, Jae-wook’s body also pauses
like the others.
Five years pass but the world remains the
same.
The guys have now grown into teenagers.
Although they have been living in isolation
for so many years, they still hope that someday,
the world will go back to normal.
Sung-min believes that when they turn twenty,
their time will resume.
They steal a little bit of money from everyone
to be rich when that happens.
However, even when they turn twenty, nothing
changes.
They slowly begin to lose hope and start to
live in the wooden house in the jungle.
One day, the isolation gets the best of Sung-min;
he screams and yells for it all to stop.
Tae-shik witnesses this from afar and loses
all hope.
Some days later, Sung-min notices that the
moon’s shape is changing, meaning that the
world is about to be resumed.
He goes looking for Tae-shik but doesn’t
find him anywhere.
He searches for him throughout the island
and eventually reaches the last cliff.
There, he discovers Tae-shik’s clothes on
the ground and registers that his friend has
jumped into the water to commit suicide.
He also jumps behind Tae-shik as the last
resort.
But at the very moment, the world resumes.
He comes out of the water and is mesmerized
by the moving nature.
After reading the journal, Soo-rin runs to
the wooden house and finally sees her friend.
They decide to tell the story to the world
but are unsure if anyone will believe them.
Meanwhile, CCTV footage shows the police that
Sung-min is in the woods.
They believe he is the kidnaper.
At night, Sung-min comes to Soo-rin’s room
for emotional support.
Since he has been living alone for such a
long time, he is scared he will harm himself
to get rid of the pain.
The next day, Tae-shik’s parents arrive
at the construction site blaming Do-kyun for
their kid’s disappearance.
They believe that the explosion in the site
killed their son, and Soo-rin is making up
stories to save her stepfather.
Meanwhile, Soo-rin and Sung-min go to the
orphanage that Sung-min used to stay in.
Soo-rin explains everything to the warden
and comes outside to call Sung-min.
However, she is dragged away by her father
right then.
Sung-min approaches his mother-like warden
and tells her everything he used to do as
a kid.
She is shocked but she still doesn’t believe
him.
Do-kyun locks Soo-rin in her room at night
but Sung-min enters through the back door
and frees her.
They run away from the house to decide what
they should do next.
Soo-rin remembers seeing a second egg in the
cave.
She suggests she uses the egg and returns
as an adult to prove to the others that Sung-min
is innocent.
However, Sung-min is against the idea because
he knows how difficult it is to live in isolation.
He would rather be named a kidnapper than
let her go through what he felt in the past
years.
Do-kyun sees that his daughter is missing
and figures she went to the wooden house after
finding a picture of her and Sung-min on her
phone.
He goes there at night, attacks Sung-min,
and tries to take Soo-rin back home.
But Sung-min knocks him out and runs away
with her.
The next day, the police investigate the wooden
house and believe that the kidnapper is manipulating
Soo-rin by making her believe he is Sung-min.
The news about Soo-rin’s disappearance is
on the TV so the police soon find the two.
A chase ensues between them and the police
when Soo-rin turns herself in to save Sung-min.
Before separating she asks him to meet her
at the cave.
Detective Ahn tries to make Soo-rin understand
that the kidnaper is lying to her but she
doesn’t believe him.
She makes an excuse of wanting to go to the
bathroom and runs away to the cave.
She brings the glowing egg out and hands it
to Sung-min but he refuses to return it to
her because he doesn’t want her to use it.
He is about to turn himself in and take the
blame for killing his friends.
He runs away into the woods as Soo-rin follows
him.
At the same time, the police arrive and chase
behind.
They stop at the end of a cliff.
An officer grabs Sung-min and pushes Soo-rin
off the cliff in the process.
The detective helps Soo-rin but ends up hanging
off the cliff with her.
Sung-min tries to save them, but before he
can, they both fall back.
To save them, Sung-min breaks the egg again
and stops time.
When Soo-rin wakes up a few seconds later,
she is on a beach with the detective.
She realizes what Sung-min has just done.
Although it has only been a moment for her,
for Sung-min it must have been another decade.
She is then taken back home.
While eating dinner, she apologizes to her
father for everything she has done and calls
him dad for the first time.
The detective comes to inquire how they survived
the fall.
Soo-rin doesn’t answer but he figures out
that she was telling the truth this entire
time.
He suggests she give a false statement to
the media and say that the kidnapper had manipulated
her.
This way, the people who are accusing her
of killing her friends along with the kidnapper
will be proved wrong.
Soo-rin is finally done telling her story
to the psychiatrist.
She is left stunned after listening to it
all and wants to write a book on it.
Some months later, Soo-rin is moving to a
different city for high school.
Before leaving, she meets the psychiatrist
who gives her the book which has now been
published.
On her way to the ferry, Soo-rin sees Sung-min
through her car window and runs to meet him
but finds no one.
But some time later, the two meet on the deck.
The movie ends as they stare at each other.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.